hi my name is Patrick and applications
engineer working at Wolfram math course
the developers of Wolfram system modeler
and well an applications engineer you
might ask what do i do many many believe
i'm working with mobile our mobile apps
well that's not quite true what I work
is with this applying valle frances the
molar and mathematica within different
applications and one of those
applications i'll talk with you here
today is within the process industry and
before i started should say that many of
the things i present here is partially
funded by a strategic innovation program
in sweden that focuses on furthering the
development of control software or
software in general with in the process
industry and try to you know move it
towards industry four-point-oh so for
those who you don't know we generally
define the process industry as something
where we have semi continuous or even a
continuous flow of production a great
great examples of this is for example
the beverage industries the food in some
food industries chemicals biofuels
medicines and you know everywhere we
have like a recipe for how you are
supposed to do things yeah for example
you have a recipe where you make coke
and then you modify it slightly and a
different ingredients and then you get
sprite I should say of the beverage
beverages are available so with these
recipes you know you input them into the
process and you should be good to go
right well not quite because when you
will you set up your process you define
okay this gets imported and then we want
coke at the other end of it but there
will always be different process
variations so how do we account for this
well to account for this we have we have
to introduce the human element and by
that i mean the the process operators
which are the type of a cog wheels of
the operation and these are very
important because you know you have a
continuous flow of production and each
one has their own station and they need
to know their station in and out they
need to know like if if something
happens at the at their point in the
process they need to be able to solve
problems in real time and also it's very
important because you know due to the
nature of the continuous flow different
stations will affect one another because
I'm doing something over here and then
people down the line will be affected
with how I solve the dif different
problems and everyone will have this if
a problem occurs in the process you know
it could be it could be for example of
we talking up beverages suddenly the
beverage flow is not as transparent as
it used to be then you first need to
well there are different ways to solve
that problem and how do you solve that
problems could be suboptimal in some
cases and I'll talk a bit about the
process operator says but for this I
will use a running example and the
running example i will use is that of a
large-scale paperboard manufacturer in
sweden and you know the paper industry
today it's not doing quite as well as it
it used to do but what they do here is
they try to compete by having really
really high high quality rather than
than high quantity but we used so let's
introduce how a paper mill works what we
have is this a bit higher what we have
is a wood pulp that you have bulb from
for example pine trees from birch trees
and you mix them together and you mix
them together with water which comes
down here and the reason why you mix it
with water is that it you spread it out
you need to spread it out the fibers in
the pulp evenly and then you put it on
to a to a drainage plate almost we
provide suction to drain the most of the
water and then you vaporize the excess
waters in heated in heated environment
and finally you have some measurements
of quality and here is where the we have
different process operators in this
process and to really get the best kind
of quality paper in the end everyone has
to know how their part of the prod of
the production effects everything down
the line so each one of these you can
you know you can a mixture with
different quotas of fibers you can mix
in different amounts of water you can
you can provide different amount of
suction here new different heat here and
then everything they will culminate into
a final measurement of quality in the
end and the quality I will focus mostly
on today is that of grammage of the
paper that comes out it's basically the
paper density and what's most important
is to have it even across across the
paper so if you for example look at the
a newspaper and you look really really
closely you'll see that there's quite a
bit of variation in those in that paper
if you do like high very high quality
print you need to have it very very
smooth and everything that I just
mentioned he goes in to to that quality
measurement and there's this always also
others like you have to have optimal
water content to optimal you know
stretching well you can actually get one
this I looked at this earlier one of the
schedules you can see that this is very
nice actually very nice paper density so
you could get a feeling for what they
are kind of striving for I think they
have a bit better but but maybe I'm
biased so this is one of the production
plants where I was doing some consulting
work and let's go into what okay so we
have the operators here they are
controlling the process they trying to
get the optimal the best paper in the
end but what are the challenges they are
facing here so I listed some of these
challenges they were facing and one is
okay so you got these operators they've
worked here for a very long time they
know their station in and out but how
did they acquire that knowledge well
they acquired it by working for a very
long time so if you get a new being
there no put it you need to put him in
charge of the of the operation but you
have this continuous flow you can just
can't just stop the machine and train
them up so you have these training
manuals that you know says okay me if
you mix these fibers it will kind of
behave like this but due to the nature
of the continuous process you have very
high dynamics it could take it could
take
I think it takes about 20 minutes from
this point up there to this point down
there or maybe even more it takes 40
minutes actually so things that people
up there are doing will affect it very
very long down line and it's very hard
to get that kind of feeling initially
also they got in every process like this
it's not just this paper process you get
lots and lots of different measurement
in in upstream of the of the final
metropolitan measurement for example one
one example of this is the length of the
fiber that comes from the from the input
and then get mixed with the water so
they measure the length of the fibers
but all the process operators there had
a very hard time understanding what that
signal even meant so they install it a
very very expensive sensor but then
really couldn't do anything with the
data that they got from it and you know
if you these fiber lengths it's
something that it varies from hour to
hour day to day basis or even well very
much seasonal and if you aren't the one
who because the operators can't affect
this thing signals themselves they have
to learn by by being there see looking
at okay so this went up what happened
but if it's happened on a seasonal basis
it's very hard to get that kind of
dynamic knowledge of the signals they
can't affect themselves and this this
paper plant for example has a very very
high throughput I think it's somewhere
around one metric ton of paper every
three minutes that comes down one of
these lines then there's multiple of
these lines so you have the operators
there that you know something that they
do within the timeframe of three minutes
will affect one metric ton of paper and
the
and the reason why we start looking at
this paper density variable especially
was because this was one of the
variables where the operator said up you
know I have to be over there at the same
time I have to be over there and adjust
all these signals at the same time it's
just everything's moving too fast and
finally this wasn't a problem for the
operators put for the higher ups they
claim that they were little to no cost
consideration taken on the floor where
we're by for example different fibers
that enters this process costs different
amount of money I think that pion is
very expensive and they have like this
is recycled paper that comes into the
process that we're almost free but for
the process operators this wasn't really
the aim of them to try and minimize the
overall cost of the process even though
they had a very very high input on how
much the process costs in running every
minute depending on how they mix the
different fibers and so we try we wanted
to solve these problems using by
creating and first creating a model of
the system and the model that we created
was based on we have all these you know
mass flows through the system so we
could create a physical model of that
all the equations for mass flows are
very very well known but we also had you
know the final the final quality
measurement the grammage deviation and
there's really not that much literature
on how this particular paper plant would
how signals work so what we did was we
combine those physical models of
physical models of the mass balance
equations with entirely black box models
that we had we had three months
of production data we had minute data in
three months where we could track this
this grammage deviation of a time we
could go back and see okay where what
did the operators change here why did
they why the grammage go up whether it
go down here and we could we could focus
on narrow down we had like here I think
we had 200 of these signals that we
could narrow down which ones were the
most important for the for the deviation
output and we also use the step
responses on those those important
variables we tried and increase them a
step see what happened and use that used
multiple such experiments for both
estimation and then some other datasets
for validations of the model and that is
quite well so the end result of that was
a a model developed in modelica that
looked looked like this now I want to
demo this a live at the this model live
so in order not to confuse with all
these variables that the operators
normally have I brought a scaled-down
version that look like this and this is
if you remember the schematic I showed
earlier this is this is the fiber coming
into the process you have you mix them
differently together and that is a
signal for the operates to use then you
have some some tanks that just it will
that whether mixing occurs and you mix
together some some water you have the
and the drying sections basically so we
created these models in system modeler
and then what we could do was we could
use that solve solve the problems that i
previously mentioned so one thing we did
was we
[Music]
here we have a like a training
simulation for we where you can interact
interacting real time with the model and
what I'm going to show here is something
that's built with Mathematica but what
you can do also is you can interact with
these models in different ways for
example you could use OPC the witch
which is a standard communication
platform within the process industry a
rather a protocol within the process
industry so you can get this like these
all this simulation information directly
in real time to and human machine
interface you know the normal places
where the operators would would interact
with the process so let me show you how
this could look and this is then built
in Mathematica so in the background
right now i'm running a real-time
simulation of that model that I've
showed that I showed previously and I
reduce the number of of the input here
but so you can see we could mess with
the amount of fibers that goes into the
system we have three here normally
there's much more we can mix different
amount of water we can drain the system
so if I add just one of the sliders here
you'll see that the that the system
responds and this is the real time the
simulation that's running in the
background and of course when you build
a model you can't capture all the
variations and so for example be the
fiber lens that I mentioned previously
we can't predict the fiber length said
that comes into the system and what we
could do then is we could estimate how
large these process deviations normally
are so so we could use this this kind of
interface to train new operators say i
should say what this is actually this is
the grammage deviations that i've talked
about very much but haven't shown
earlier so we can track this in real
time in a sim
later the environment and this blue this
black line here would be for example the
target and they have different targets
depending on different paper qualities
so to go back to the noise to make it
more realistic we can see that it's
static now but if we add some noise it
gets more into something that the
operators would encounter in real life
so this could be something that they can
use to train train dynamics to operators
for let's see if it's actually wasn't
that much noise to begin with that the
train operators on how the system how
the system dynamics behaves and this was
well and good for the for the first
problem that I mentioned but it's still
and of course you can use with you you
get a better understanding for the other
problems but we wanted to be able to
help the operators you know in the daily
lives also not just train new operators
so we took this one step further and you
know we said we said we had like we have
our model of the system we can we can
predict what happens if you do different
inputs so for example yeah if I just
decided what will happen well we can
predict that what will happen in the
future and then we created a prediction
environment so i can start this here we
will see that this dotted line here
shows where the process is heading
heading given be the estimated states
it's estimated because there is noise
that the simulation don't know about and
given the current input and if i change
the input here you'll see that it gets
much much easier to you know I thought
right i'm not i'm not really a process
operator here but they are much better
at this than me than I am
all right yeah in any way in any case
you could kind of get it to move you can
easier get it to move into the into the
target area by knowing okay i change
this how will it affect and you can you
can do this protect predictions before
you enter these these input values you
can you don't have to you know commit to
it you can find okay I want to do this
will it help the process okay it won't
then find some some place some something
else to do and now you know it's no so
f2 changes continuously right and this
this helps in some ways in you know the
the all the signals they have they get a
better because this takes into account
the mesh measured disturbance signals
such as the fiber length so this also
helps them in that case but we still
have to solve the the cost consideration
and I'm not going to go into every
specifics of it but and if someone wants
to know more about how this works you're
please come down to please come and talk
to me after this but we implemented
model predictive control which is you
take you take the model of the system
you have you make a discrete version of
it and you post it as an optimization
problem so we could say for example that
all right did custard cost us this and
this much to deviate from the target
level the target grammage deviation and
it cost us this and this much to use
this fiber and then then suddenly you
have an optimization problem that you
can solve and so we implemented that and
I can let's see if I put on the all
right only two so when I start this it
will know it I totally they can control
every of these every of these slider so
I start this and it will control these
sliders for me
and how does that in real time and you
know pretty it estimates the noise and
then in every time instant solves this
optimization problem in order to keep as
close to the reference as possible given
the the cost of deviating from a
reference and also use the fiber and
here i think i set the fiber number
three to be the cheapest one so it's
it's tend tends to use that if it's
possible to to get a good signal even
though you're using it and i guess i
could i can adjust just the weight in
real time so say okay now suddenly this
there's a problem we we're not getting
in a pie and this cost is very much so
hello let's just drag this up let's see
if it's so now it will stop using that
ok now the this fiber here costs very
much ok then it stops using it as start
using the other ones so the verdict was
that we wanted to try this in different
industries also and we because we
realized that you know the same
principles they can be applied almost
everywhere in the process industry
everyone has these kinds of problems
they've for problems that i mentioned
and one of the applications where we
where we started applying it was the
production of bioethanol and there you
have you put grain mix it with water at
least in sweden here in the US i think
you do it with the mace but in sweden
you put a lot of cereal grain water and
then enzymes and it makes it together so
one problem they had was that the
viscosity of the mixture was getting too
high the enzyme that they used to keep
the viscosity down costs a lot of money
so there's a trade-off there so one
thing is to you know you can learn the
operators how with these kinds of
enzymes will affect the viscosity of a
time and this is also the dynamic system
and sank
kinetic breakdown takes take some time
before the before the resulting effect
will be seen for the operator so you can
use the same kind of principles to train
train it and we also in lab scale have
applied this model predictive control we
post an optimization problem for former
controller to you know keep their and
somatic here and somatic usage as low as
possible while a while keeping the
viscosity as at an acceptable level
right and let's see I'm really running
out of time but we have some other talks
on system ola john had a talk yesterday
on what we actually released a new verse
and I'm sister modeler yesterday two
days ago yesterday yesterday so in case
you missed that she comman talk to us
and we would be happy to tell you a bit
about what's the what's new in sister
modeler also this talk here and later in
the day me and John will give a
presentation on how system ola can be
used in in education and it's kind of
the same principles actually as the ones
I showed here where you know you get to
interact with things in real time and it
gives you the intuition you need to to
really understand the system and then
tomorrow Neil singer here has a talk on
how to rapidly rapidly prototype
different systems and he has a really
cool demonstration down in basement you
should check it out it's a balancing
plate and I think you're going to talk a
bit about it tomorrow also a port on
things and also a talk tomorrow on how
fuel cells have been modeled in the
system habla and the oh actually i
should mention the demonstration i
showed you here when I'm down in the
basement here it is available if you
want to interact with these sliders
yourself you want to know a bit more
about the system
how it works learn about model
predictive control come come and visit
our booth down there I'll be happy to
talk a bit more about it so thank you
[Applause]